we've got a voicemail number two one
nine to david p here's a voicemail that
came in asking about new White House
press secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders
hey David
this is tenkara calling from Binghamton
New York
I was just wondering I've been watching
Sarah Huckabee Sanders do these press
conferences and she seems to know
absolutely nothing that's going on in
the White House the same thing with Sean
Spicer do you feel bad for these people
no that's just what these people deserve
right it's not about whether they
deserve it or not they took a job the
first time they're asked to lie or kept
out of the loop in a way that
jeopardizes their integrity they could
resign or they could say I'm not going
to do this anymore and Sean Spicer
eventually resigned supposedly because
of the hiring of scaramouche II I don't
feel bad for them I mean I don't relish
the destruction of anyone's political
career but the you don't have to work at
the White House right I started to take
pity on Sean spike sir just because he's
such a laughingstock IV Sarah Huckabee
Sanders she's actually pretty good at
that job it's an indefensible position
that she has to defend a lot of the time
there but she's quite skilled at it all
right well I don't feel bad for him
I do take pity on the fact that they've
got to deal with this nonsense
but I don't feel bad in that sense we've
got a fantastic bonus show for you today
if you're not a member sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership and that
will give you access to the world-famous
bonus show I will speak to you then